these are decisive days
for our negotiations with the united
kingdom there has been
genuine progress on a number of
important questions
but frankly i cannot tell you today
if in the end there will be a deal of
course we prefer to have an agreement
but one thing is clear whatever the
outcome
there has to be and there will be a
clear difference
between being a full member of the union
and being just a valued partner
so inside what did you know
but there is also good news the european
commission by now has secured contracts
on vaccines
with six pharmaceutical companies the
first european citizens
might already be vaccinated before the
end of december
and there's finally light at the end of
the tunnel
and yes as i've said vaccines are
important but what counts
is vaccinations member states must get
ready now
because this is our ticket out of the
pandemic
from brexit to the fight against the
pandemic
from the budget to the fight against
terrorists
it is when we manage to join forces
that we europeans can achieve the most
it is when we negotiate hard and then
stick to the compromise
found that we move forward best
this is how we will finally leave the
corona world and continue
to build our future langley europa
long live europe vivo merci